one of the common visions for all type  of labs is that they will make use of  the automation and digitalization so the  digital infrastructure needs to take  into account  the large volume and variety of data  that is being  produced some later on challenges can be  avoided if the organizations have data  centricity in mind when implementing the  new systems and workflows and  automations  and one of the general  challenges that all  labs are facing  is how to capture this large amount of  data that is being produced  including the contextual data  in a fair format which means to be  findable to be accessible to be  interoperable and reusable  and how to redesign  the current paper-based workflow